I started using cocaine and
Lsd when I was 12 years old.
I stopped taking LSD when I jumped out
of a window and fractured two of my ribs.
However, I still use drugs
due to my depression and
because they helped me forget
everything.
12 years old.
That's young.
My Dad has been a heavy alcoholic all my
life now he's suffering from liver and
kidney failure because he won't stop
ounce speak to him anymore and ignore his
calls.
I had a relative in my life who
also had a drinking problem.
There are a lot of feelings that come
with it and there's a lot of rage that
comes with it. I don't blame you
for not wanting to talk to him, but
try if he can find it in yourself.
I'm not saying forgive.
I think that may help them a lot too
because it's an addiction as a disease.
I stole money from my boss to
support my gambling addiction.
He ended accuser accusing.
My mom was stealing it.
The reason I'm
this really like this was me to the t,
but
I have a lot of people around me that a
don't allow me to do this and if I do do
it, they're there for me. If
you want the help, it's there.
At the age of 11,
I sought a comfort of pornography due
to feeling that my parents saw me as
inadequate.
Every moment I was anxious that my secret
would be exposed and that my perceived
reality would become real.
That nobody could love me.
I've felt for a long time that nobody
could love me and I thought that my
parents didn't think that
I was adequate either.
And reaching for other things to fill
that hole is really common. Yeah.
And I can empathize with that.
I'm only 16.
I've been valley addiction
with prescription pain
medication that I received for
an injury three years ago.
Oh,
we read that one.
Okay.
I'm only 16 and barely addiction.
It's prescription pain medication that I
received for an injury three years ago.
I don't want to die this young,
but I'm too afraid.
Totally parents.
Um,
I know it's like to be I did to the drug
is 16 since I been getting high as this
house.
14 surely 16 million got so much.
Hope so much live for it and
I probably hear that a lot.
And you don't believe it. I had no, I
didn't. It's hard to have that secret.
I get it. But um, if you keep holding
that pain in, it's going to kill you.
My best friend is addicted to taking drugs
to help her cope with her depression.
And one of the few people who know it
feels like I'm carrying something heavy
around with me.
I feel like you should try to talk to
her and help her get some help before it
gets too late because
I had to deal with that.
I had to watch my own boyfriend
passed away because I'm,
I couldn't really help him.
Hmm.
Okay.
I am diagnosed with severe depression
and I'm addicted to cutting myself.
I've only told one person about this and
I know deep down they're disappointed
in me. I wish someone could
support me without judgment.
Okay.
I've done a lot of things
to cope with my depression.
It's been almost a year since
the night,
and I never ever thought it was possible
to go that long without it ever.
If you don't believe in yourself and
no one's there to tell you that they
believe in you, then I do.
And so many other people do
never talked about that before.
You know,
when we go to support groups
or meetings or whatever it is,
you put our problems out there because
unfortunately there's other people that
have had this happen to them.
You know, we are not alone.
You know, there's always
somebody, no matter what it is.